the European Parliament the European
Commission the European Court of
Auditors the European Court of Justice
any piece Brussels pass book breaks it
the EU seems really complicated it's
made up of 7 EU institutions and even
more lower-level bodies spread out over
4 countries with hundreds of buildings
and employees traveling back and forth
to make it even more confusing two of
these institutions sound the same and
sit in the same building while having
different functions the European Council
not to be confused with the Council of
the EU which is also known colloquially
as Council of Ministers confused yet
tell me about it this complexity is one
of the reasons why some experts say many
Europeans are indifferent about EU
politics one and half of them didn't
even vote in the last European elections
but the EU and especially its laws are
important it represents roughly half a
billion people spread over 28 countries
take that in for a second the EU doesn't
just make laws that affect these people
from what they can buy at supermarkets
to where they can live many of these
laws also have an impact on the rest of
the world think agriculture food
standards trade agreements that are
protection consumer rights climate
change migration so let me break down
for you how are you peon law actually
gets proposed and voted on who's
involved and why it's so complex because
of course there's a reason for that
in order for 28 different nations to
agree on common rules and regulations
with everyone having a fair share and
say a complex system had to be
established that grew more and more so
the more nations joined the union by
design the EU was organized in a way to
create checks and balances and make sure
that no one not one country or
institution or person has all of the
power so when it comes to lawmaking
here's how that was done it all starts
with the European Council
that's the institution it gets to decide
on the general direction and the
priorities of the you this is what the
leaders of all EU Member States
so think makka makka sanchez need
together with the President of the
European Council currently the sky here
dohno chose to set the political agenda
of the EU next the political agenda has
passed on to the European Commission
this is the main organization and the EU
that proposes new laws
but cannot bother them that's important
it's another way of diverting power
there are 28 commissioners each members
day it gets to a point one to represent
them another measure to reinforce checks
and balances together with the president
of the Commission currently jean-claude
Yuka these commissioners debate which
lost they think should be passed once
the commissioners have agreed on a lot
I'd like to propose it gets Hannah to to
other EU institutions the European
Parliament and the Council of the
European Union these are the only two
institutions within the EU that get to
adopt laws most of the time together
sometimes alone it depends I told you
it's complicated but I'll walk you
through it so bear with me let's start
with the European Parliament it's the
second biggest Parliament in the world
and it's the only organization within
the EU where representatives or any
piece are directly elected by the
European people every five years each
member state gets a fixed number of any
piece proportional to their population
the most important task is to debate and
vote on last suggested by the
Commissioner from a ban on single-use
plastics to limits to banker bonuses
capping the price of mobile phone calls
within the EU and the safety of
e-cigarettes but here's the catch even
if the MEP s agree Allah should be
passed they cannot do it alone they do
so in what's called a coalition with the
Council of the European Union this is
the institution where the governments of
the EU member states have their say and
defend their national interests the
council is comprised of the national
ministers of each member state for
example the Minister for environment
agriculture and fisheries or justice and
Home Affairs in the vast majority of
cases Allah can only pass of both the
European Parliament and the council
agree it should be adopted
why yep you got it checks and balances
okay deep breath you've almost made it
to the end well done three more
institutions to talk about
there's the European Court of Justice
basically the EU Supreme Court it's
comprised of one judge from each member
state I don't have to do the whole
checks and balances thing again I think
you get it by now right
they make sure countries and EU
institutions abide by you law there's
also the European Central Bank which is
based in Frankfurt to symbolise its
independence from political control and
there's the European Court of
but both of these institutions deal with
money I shall applause so I won't bother
you with details so what have we learned
today well that there are a lot of EU
institutions in different cities with
different roles and functions some set
the agenda at as proposed new laws
others would own them and others still
make sure they're being followed
but it's this complex structure that
makes it less likely that one country
institution or person can become too
dominant so it may be hard to keep up
with who's doing what and who's in
charge but that's exactly the point in
the end it's all about consensus and
then times like these isn't that an
achievement in itself